appello a tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo fantasmagorico video io
sono qua dj oggi siamo subito molto
particolare tra l'altro io voi mettete
fare questo da un sacco di tempo però
non ho mai avuto modo di farlo perché
ultimamente ero in giro poi uscito col
guy quindi video come support guys
adesso al momento c'è da qualche anno
credo una pincher di youtube come parlo
ben genico feature questo video
incredibile lasciate light ragazza
fincher che ti permette di vedere quali
sono le persone iscritte al tuo canale
che hanno più iscritti o che ti fa
proprio una classifica dei canali che
hanno più iscritti che sono iscritti
altro canale ok rivelerò quali sono i
canali youtube con più iscritti iscritti
a me questa classifica non comprende
tutti come tutte le persone con bizkit
iscritte al mio canale o comunque al
canale di chi la guarda perché come c'è
scritto dalla schermata da dove lo sto
consultando iscritti include solo gli
utenti che hanno reso pubbliche le loro
iscrizioni
allora ho cambiato maglia per rendere
tutto il più serio possibile comincia il
primo dei 130 canali con più iscritti in
assoluto sul sogno canale e quanto 90
grazie partorienti di questa classifica
complimenti per il centrocampo ha
innanzi tutto grazie mille del supporto
un bacino
subito dopo signore e signori agita la
classifica abbiamo nichi box chi è nei
box caso panichi box è semplicemente la
persona con la quale ho iniziato a fare
video senza la quale non sarà il banco
qua fare questo quindi è grazie a lui se
esisto più po come mia mamma 104 mila
iscritti andiamo su total si è iscritta
solo perché è venuta una volta a casa
mia da con il gruppo di charlie cesca e
quindi sono anzi sarebbe anche scritta
quindi la speriamo signori e signori con
116 mila iscritti
vittorio brumotti grazie caro grazie
mille ti seguo da quando vai con la bici
sugli spacciatori
aumentiamo un pochino l'asticella e
arriviamo a rtv
vi ringrazio tanto anche perché conosco
le tue cui sei fantastico guardatevi
quella direzione di quelle del signore
degli anelli
secondo me sei un mago arriviamo a 146
mila iscritti con un'iscrizione doc da
parte del buon ciccio merino grazie caro
ti voglio bene ti mando un bacio enorme
sulla bocca perché siamo veri amici
adesso iniziamo i 200.000 iscrive
200mila e titti poi si assottiglia e la
lista tranquilla adesso iniziano nomi
pazzeschi no che quelli prima non lo
fosse senza nulla togliere sto dicendo
non fanno i fascicoli di merda frigida
il gatto sul tubo 205 mila iscritti
grazie signor gatto un bacio chiuso di
scrivere tutti siamo iscritti al suo
canale grazie signor gatto o poi abbiamo
una tripletta ad hoc secondo me la
mettiamo le mettiamo proprio triplo
amico andrè mangaka 96 e victor laslo
perché sono tre persone che stimo molto
vi ringrazio ma il bacino anche se vitto
alloggio ha fatto recensione in berlin
therapy però ha ragione perché
effettivamente l'intervento a me appena
superiamo lo scalino dei 300.000
troviamo il maestro proprio lui ma è
solo youtube anche io e scritto al mio
canale non so se gli arriverà mai questo
video ringrazio maestro mi dispiace che
abbia smesso di fare video nell'ultimo
anno
io seguivo sicuramente abbiamo subito
dopo youtube o anche io ad honorem
jacqueline meravigliosa charlie che
effettivamente ha un sacco di iscritti
non pensavo così con scherzi voglio bene
e ha anche diretto un mio video una
volta a e preparatevi perché la prossima
settimana sabato uscirà un video anche
con lei e cesca fare molto
detto così sono male gli avanti subito
dopo il buon pietro che non fa più vito
dal 1800
ma è comunque c'è e ce lo teniamo grazie
pietro troviamo come prima persona
superato i 500.000 iscritti il
meraviglioso cibo siamo arrivati ai top
30 ci saranno tre tabelloni nel fatto
che compariranno e mi sposto perfetto
trattare la palla pria il tabellone
questi sono gli iscritti di questi sono
dal 30 al 20 ok bamber forti numero 40
march grazie khatri centro leccesi
andrea 20 legna blackjack grazie caro
grazie mille dopodiché abbiamo velox
grazie mille no perché abbiamo che noi
ha giustamente anche perché
effettivamente che noi ha un sacco di
iscritti mazzantica chi si dice che noi
subito dopo che noi abbiamo alb.or
gianandrea con ora over da bing vabbè e
gian
sono talmente in giappone insieme grazie
che di scritto caro subito dopo a me
l'aspettavo che grazie simone mi sa che
cosa sai cosa mi è sempre sembrata
quella cacchina di quella di isaac bye
bye nico baytech non so se c'è mai
giocato che ci sono le cacche mostri non
c'entra una serie charlotte m non ho
presente perché mi sa che un canale un
po più aiom programmatica tre gol
grazie mille per l'iscrizione giovanni
pons the family che aveva il bronzo
tutti in modo giusto
grazie cari un bacino quali sono dei
nomi un po particolare elisa marino
grazie cara grazie mille
accame vanno ne aveva proprio storia
youtube da secolare adriano spink erano
conosciuti una volta parte c'era questo
evento youtube
drago galaxy luke 43 16 l'us cronicas di
alfredo che lo spagnolo gg eccolo il gg
number one guidi sono proprio uno visto
per vecchio non conosco i canali nostro
grazie e complimenti perché se quanti
arrivato un milione arrivati due bolle o
il buon leo de carli allo ragazzi
leonardo non lo sento da tanto spero
stia bene torno in spagna un bacio jack
nobile signore signori il mago che
compare anche lui i nomi sta diventato
veramente grossi doctor vendetta
grazie caro eleonora olivier ha appena
superato il migliaio di iscritti e non
ero lì piedi pampers tim powers tv all
news channel e dico questi primi 5
grazie cari super gentili winx club
i dieci cosa comunque next abbiamo cup
template gas è caro grazie mille numero
13 gli archi dalle grate occhiata ho
capito che sky a chi tale perché nei
video è che ho nominato jackie tale è
perché io ho la gente non nel cuore
capito complimenti per il video
soprattutto quello del pattino
spettacolare bravo alex kidd tv italiano
credo che sia un canale di quelli per
bimbi tradotto in italiano e the right
game
il numero 10 f 160 on a bernheim capo ii
square e di classe gabon e bacio pro
vedo vedo
proprio lui che a te caro grazie mille
ti voglio bene non ci diamo un sacco
spero tu stia bene anche la sua grande
mascella pianto che o al proprio loro
proprio loro 1 intanto sono uno degli
otto ragazzi non l'ho mai detto perché
tra i membri di autogol ci sono anch'io
se guardate bene la foto alla snav six
abbiamo la sabri abbiamo davvero
superato i 2 milioni iscritti grazie
sapevi aver sentito il mio canale al
numero 5 hicks morning grazie caro non
ci vediamo in un sacco spero di vederti
presto a me grazie caro voglio preziosi
anche conosciuto come ma gallico a
milano con 2,62 milioni di iscritti
tiago bionic
che non ho idea di chi sia credo che è
un e noi hutu bear spagnolo praticamente
noi dove spagnolo grazie al secondo
posto abbiamo 6,5 milioni iscritti
quindi più dei miei scritti mass
yourself che è un canale di anche questo
spagnolo e metto a ridere è un canale
noi inglesi grazie al primo posto e qua
qua qua siamo veramente all'estremo al
primo posto youtuber che hanno più
iscritti che svestiti al mio canale
prestiti pubblici 32 milioni di iscritti
lucas neto lucas tum
non ho capito bene credo sia un canale
per piccini vedo anche che fa un
miliardo di visualizzazioni
ok 14 miliardi non scherzavo bene spero
che mi sia piaciuto come ti piace anche
vari social come mio dovere archiviare
senza 27enne come sempre ci vediamo ad
un proprio video bella ragazza
[Musica]